in our session with sir Mike rake of the
chairman of bt we had a session about
innovation intrapreneurship how mature
or growing companies can foster the
entrepreneurial spirit and ensure that
they balance the short term success
focus on cash flow and margins and
profits with building the appropriate
future without about innovation moving
outside the corporate lab moving outside
specialized units and ensuring that it
becomes a quest for better solutions and
ensuring that we have the right culture
and structures that can promote and
innovative spirit a big challenge for
many companies that need not just to
create new products but also adapt to a
changing environment and what's happened
recently in the Arab world is a reminder
that we need to be agile not just a
normative